es ist die wahrscheinlich größte
energiequelle der welt mit hahn hydrant
am meeresgrund ist methan in eis
gebunden das methanhydrat doch bisher
war es nicht möglich das gas zu fördern
das hat sich jetzt geändert china und
japan konnten zum ersten mal dieses
brennbares fördern 28 milliarden
kubikmeter davon gibt es auf der erde im
vergleich dazu 35 milliarden kubikmeter
erdgas wurden letztes jahr weltweit
gefördert ein tausendstel der
methanhydrat menge doch es geht ein
unheimliches risiko von den vorkommen
aus das thema jetzt den krieg zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen die
siebziger jahren hätten vielleicht noch
alle jubiliert in den zeiten der ölkrise
hätte sich jeder über neue brennbare
fossile energieträger gefreut egal ob
damit noch mehr co2 in die atmosphäre
gelangt aber auch heute wird seltsam und
kritisch über die erste förderung von
methanhydrat berichtet china freut sich
über eine energierevolution von einer
bohrinsel im südchinesischen meer ziehen
es geschafft neben japan erstmals mit
der hydra aus einer tiefe von 1266
metern zu fördern dabei ist immerhin
eine fördermenge von täglich 16 tausend
kubikmetern volumen und damit liegen sie
deutlich vor den japanern die noch nicht
solche mengen erzielt haben in diesem
nicht versteht man immer mehr wie
bedeutsam das südchinesische meer für
china ist und warum die großmacht zu
aggressiv entgegen internationalem recht
künstliche inseln aufgeschüttet hat um
territorialansprüche geltend zu machen
erst im januar hatten chinesische
militärs einen krieg gegen die usa
deswegen nicht ausgeschlossen für china
ist das methanhydrat enorm wichtig das
riesige land verfügt nur über wenig
erdöl und dementsprechend war die
bohrung südlich von hongkong ein
riesiger durchbruch das land könnte so
unabhängig von importen werden und die
wirtschaft könnte noch schneller wachsen
bisher waren die anstrengungen das
methanhydrat zu gewinnen nicht von
erfolg gekrönt denn nur ein kleiner teil
der vorkommen dass er ist so leicht
erreichbar wie im südchinesischen meer
und die methanhydrate wind gefährlich
vor 8000 jahren sind wahrscheinlich
riesige mengen am meeresboden explodiert
und haben einen unglaublichen tsunami
auf der nordsee ausgelöst
eine bis zu sechs meter hohe flutwelle
bildete sich damals vor der norwegischen
küste materialwissenschaftler fürchten
nun dass der abbau ähnliche kräfte
freisetzen können sie das material ist
extrem instabil und bei der zerstörung
der struktur wird das gasthaus frei
gewählten es könnte zu einer ähnlichen
kettenreaktion kommen die vor 8000
jahren und damit gelangt ein viel
schlimmeres treibhausgas in die
atmosphäre
methan ist ein 20 fach wirksameres
treibhausgas als kohlendioxid gott
verdankt wird es aber schneller abgebaut
mehr über neue energieträger kernfusion
regenerative energien und so weiter
gefolgt erfahrt ihr natürlich hier bei
klicks um regelmäßig dafür mir hier ein
abo aufs auge drücken und nicht den auf
die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter
mit einem durchbruch bei der kernfusion
vielleicht kommt sie doch schneller als
wir denken einfach draufklicken
ansonsten bis dann glatt an